lawmakers in the US state of Alabama
have approved the country's toughest
abortion law the state Senate voted 25
to 6 to outlaw abortion at any stage of
pregnancy
even if that pregnancy resulted from
incest or rape it would also send
doctors who perform abortion to prison
for life outside the legislature women's
groups protested the bill it will now go
to the state governor for her approval
now the minority Democrats denounced the
law but the majority Republicans
supported it and they say they want this
bill to end up in the US as top court so
that it will rule on whether abortion is
legal hopefully get to the Supreme Court
and have them revisit the actual
decision which was is the baby in a womb
a person but why do I want to control
our bodies I will never ever know our
reporter Peter Dahl has been looking
into this story for us and joins us in
our studio thanks Peter so we've seen
that Alabama Alabama lawmakers have now
passed us into law it'll now land on the
governor's desk what's gonna happen next
right the governor has said that she'll
not sign anything before she's seen the
full bill but she's known as a strongly
religious instantly conservative
Republican in fact it was one of her
central issues when she ran for governor
at the time she said I believe every
life is precious as a pro-life governor
I'll always fight to protect the unborn
and she does have the backing of a
majority of Alabama's just last November
voters there voted overwhelmingly to
amend their state constitution to
recognize the rights of the unborn to
ban funding for abortion 59% voted in
favor of that amendment all right so the
majority of Alabamans stand behind her
but we should say this is still very
controversial
there was a very heated debate on the
floor of the state legislature in
Alabama and on top of that we've seen a
big backlash across the u.s. a
controversy online as well tell us about
that yeah that's right I mean this has
been long been a hugely divisive issue
and it's become increasingly along
partisan lines Democrats including
several prominent
and presidential candidates busy lined
up to denounce this bill saying they'll
not let this stand and it is all but
starting to go to the courts just
moments after the bill was passed the
civil liberties organization the ACLU
tweeted abortion is not a crime it's a
constitutional right we'll sue to stop
this law from ever taking effect and
that wouldn't be the first time that the
eighth of you has battled Alabama in
court in 2016 the state had to pay the
ace of you 1.7 million dollars when it
was challenged over another attempt to
restrict abortions and that was struck
down by federal courts all right Peter
put this into context for us because
this is not just about Alabama it is the
latest in a series of states that have
passed legislation to restrict abortion
so what are we looking at what's
happening and where is this headed right
I mean just last week Georgia became the
fourth state this year to pass a
so-called heartbeat bill that bans
abortions after six weeks which is when
doctors can generally detect the fetuses
heart beat up until now such bills have
been successfully struck down and that's
because abortion is a constitutional
right that has to do with the landmark
1973 Supreme Court case Roby weight
which guaranteed the right to abortion
in the United States but Republicans and
now believe that they have a chance to
overturn that law that's because the
balance on the Supreme Court has shifted
since President Donald Trump became
president he's had the rare opportunity
to appoint two judges Neal Gorsuch and
Brett Kavanaugh both of whom have been
known to come out and is be critically
about roe v-- wade so Republicans
calculus now is that they'll push as
many of these anti-abortion laws as
possible hoping they'll get challenged
or we're almost expecting they'll get
challenged that will then eventually end
up in front of the Supreme Court where
they then hope they now have the support
to have abortion overturned all right
our reporter Peter dalla following this
story for us thank you so much Peter
thank you